everyone and welcome to the second
session of the from the second quantum
session
so also welcome to people from uh who
are joining us from zoom on uh from ciqc
and uh qsa
so um i should say that uh if you you
know even if you're on zoom you can ask
questions either through chat or or or
um you could even ask a live question so
the we'll start with anurag
who will tell us about approximation
theory and quantum antibody systems
thanks so much uh
is the sound clear
okay
so uh thanks again for joining uh
i'll be speaking about approximation
theory in many body systems
well the polynomials are the favorite
objects of
all computer scientists
and this talk is of similar nature but
in this particular case i'll talk about
a specific application of polynomials to
physics related systems
and i believe that there might be some
uh results and application that might
not have been
seen earlier
uh
apologies if someone noticed that the
talk title has changed i just thought
that
another talk on hamilton complexity
would be nice for the audience
so uh
we'll be speaking we'll be discussing
about a certain class of systems which
are
known as quantum antibody systems on
on a in a physical setup so for example
in this picture you see
a set of dots which are a collection of
particles
uh they're arranged on a two dimensional
lattice
and they're interacting locally which is
governed by the laws of nature the laws
of nature do not permit
very long-range interaction in a strong
way so this sort of captures that
property
so for example um
here you can see
that the interaction is localized to
four spins like if you think of each
placket as
capturing an interaction
so what does this system look like
mathematically
uh it is it is given by something known
as a hamiltonian
which captures the locality of these
interactions so here the hamiltonian is
a sum over
i and j which label the plackets under
some limbic
and
for each ij the placket hij let's say
this red one over here
acts only on the
particles
in the placket and acts as identity
everywhere else
so
um
this this set of systems or
generalizations of it have been
extremely important in physics for over
a century
a few few states here which are
particularly interesting
first is known as the ground state which
is the smallest
eigenvector with the smallest eigenvalue
and this is where the system is expected
to be at very very low temperatures
another states are gibb states which
look uh look in this particular uh
exponential form
and they describe the system at high
temperatures uh and
uh folks from machine learning community
and so on would recognize these as
uh
as graphical models are on also in a
classical system so these are all
generations of that
but turns out that these systems these
states are really large
so uh if there are n times l
particles in this picture
then these states are very big matrices
of two to the n times l and two to the n
cell dimension
and uh understanding that property is
very very rare so uh in the past hundred
years i'd say there has been
rare cases where uh people have exactly
identified what the states look like
despite this complexity it's quite
remarkable that these states exhibit
some general features
so one example is exponential decay of
correlation
which
i won't define it precisely but one
could recognize it in various domains as
the
as basically the correlation function
between certain things that you're
observing
similarly there are other properties
known as area laws of antagonia entropy
and also classical simulation algorithms
because decision systems are so complex
people also want to try and simulate it
so these generic features have been
popping up lots and lots of times
so in this talk uh uh as i promised
earlier i will be
speaking about a particular role of
approximation theory and these generic
features
and
the starting point is a collection of
results that that that really
appeal to me
so let me describe those
so
in 2008 hastings showed that the ground
states of gap hamiltonians in one
dimension they satisfy an area law with
an entanglement that scales as
exponential and one over the gap of the
hammer joint
this result was a major breakthrough in
the field and remarkably a few years
later uh
and co-authors working here at berkeley
they exponentially improve this result
to one hour gap
there's another set of results so
hastings again showed uh well now in the
past uh around in 2003
that the ground states satisfy what is
known as a decay of correlation which
means that the correlation function it
gets weaker as the distance between
things that you're observing gets
further away
and the co and the rate of decay is
given by the gap of the hamiltonian
this result is tight for
gapped hamiltonians but it turns out
that
in
another work that came out very recently
not very recently but five years ago
huang and gossip showed that
this result can be improved for a
special class of systems
so what are these systems so
uh
these uh this hastings the result was
tied for a class of systems which are
known as
frustrated systems which could be seen
as you know the quantum versions of
unsatisfied csps for example
gossip and huang and gossip result it
applies to
uh
quantum versions of satisfied csps which
are known as precision free systems
and this improvement of square squared
of gate was square for gap was quite
remarkable in my opinion because this
was tight for freshener systems
so what underlies these results uh both
these improvements that i've shown here
is
the same object which is the chebyshev
polynomials which comes from
approximation theory and it's quite
remarkable that in these results that
one can obtain almost tight results from
the chebyshev point of view which
in in in the prior applications uh using
the techniques of hastings required some
uh highly non-trivial tools from uh
analysis
so uh in i'll be presenting uh let me
see how much time do i have
five minutes yeah so in the five minutes
i'll go over five slides and i'll be uh
presenting
uh my own work in in this direction
pushing this line of research
so uh before that let me quickly tell
you what these chebyshev polymers are
so the chebyshev polymers uh
well they their role comes in the
following way so imagine a function f
which takes a value a large value at a
certain
x let's say xq to min
and it's zero otherwise
so
uh clearly this is a very very
complicated function it peaks at a
single point approximation to it is not
possible with any low degree polynomial
but if you promise that you only care
about approximation in a certain regime
then chebyshev followers are known to be
the best objects that that achieve this
task
and the bottom line is that f of h is
the ground state of the hamiltonian and
c of h is the best low degree
approximation to the to the function
so that's where the chebyshev polynomial
modally comes in in this whole area
so
the first result that i talked about
concerns the gibbs states that i showed
you earlier
in one dimension these gibbs states
which are very very important in physics
to predict
the behavior at high temperatures
simulating them is a very standard task
and
in heuristic methods simulating them
usually requires just linear time linear
the number of particles it doesn't take
more than that
but any rigorous proof that there is a
simulation method
uh in the prior works required a lot of
time so for example it required a high
polynomial
time to run
in a recent work with kuahara and
alumbra we showed that for a large range
of temperature which actually matches
for physical systems
this runtime can be strictly improved to
almost linear
and this linearity
simply comes from the optimal
approximation to the exponential
function that is obtained by a chebyshev
polynomial
and certain features of these
polynomials uh really help shape this
near linear time behavior which you know
which prior works did not do not have
using other kind of approximations
next example uh uh concerns a graph and
a picture i'm not very good at these
pictures but i'll try to relay the main
ideas
uh
so a certain interesting class of
quantum states i discovered recently uh
by in the group of micheloken
and this image is particularly taken
from uh from this this work which
uh shows studies the entanglement
behavior of these states
so in this picture you see a
many body system and each dot here
corresponds to a quantum state which is
an eigen state of the hamiltonian
there are a lot of dots here but what's
the most interesting interesting dots
are the ones at the bottom which will
show up form a curve
and those dots are known as scar states
they are somehow outliers in this
picture
so this picture denotes uh
labels the energy eigen values in the x
axis and the entropy of these states the
entanglement neutral in the y axis
and what you notice is that these states
are particularly small entropy which is
a rare example which probably wasn't
believed earlier
at the same time what you notice
is that the entropy
within these states gets smaller as you
go to lower energy it somehow peaks at
the middle energy and then gets higher
lower again in the lower energy so we
explained uh so this is what happens the
entire increases in a nice way and then
decreases again
so so in a recent work we basically we
explained this with this phenomena using
polynomials again
this is not chebyshev followers but
these are related volumes and i guess if
i were to give a one line statement to
computer scientists here especially
those who are uh familiar with
approximation theory
if you note that the or function which
has hamming weight one
it requires a lower degree to
approximate compared to the majority
function which has which has hamming
weight no2 it speaks at a middle point
so this is the same feature that that
exhibit that is executed here the
entanglement in these states peaks
according to the energy of the system
and that's exactly what is what is
reflected in this
in what we will see in the experiments
next example will be uh will be about
the uh about computing the spectral gap
itself as i mentioned the spectral gap
plays a key role in many of these
systems
and so i'll be finishing very soon and
uh computing them is very hard but then
there is a class of examples that have
been the class of techniques that have
been that have been developed
what they do is that they
instead of computing the gap on the full
system they try to compute the gap on a
smaller set of systems
and if the gap is large enough in the
smaller system then you can prove that
there's a large gap in the bigger system
so this relation between this local gap
and the global gap
it has been explored very a lot in the
past few years
and
in various in certain cases the it was
shown that the tight relation between
the two holes using some techniques that
were there around the main body system
uh in a recent work i showed that uh
this relation holds for all the all
dimensions all boundary conditions
uh and the source of this improvement uh
that you see here comes again from
chebyshev following as well there's no
surprise where this is going
okay so uh in the final slide i'll talk
about uh
area laws back again going back to area
laws in 2d systems now so in the 2d
systems area laws are very big open
questions uh and uh and there's no proof
yet that gapped systems into dimension
they exhibit parallel behavior
uh looking into this this line of
problems into this particular problem uh
with it
and david gosset we asked the following
question uh recently which is let's go
back to the one day systems what is the
optimal polynomial approximation to the
ground states of 1d
local returning systems as i showed
chebyshev follow me seems to be the
optimal one as a function of the
hamiltonian but is there something
better that can be done
so what we showed is that if you assume
certain property first is the
frustration free assumption that i
already introduced earlier and next is
the local gap assumption which i
introduced quickly in the previous slide
then a multivariate polynomial of the
hamiltonian can significantly improve
upon the chebyshev behavior
when you're interested in very very
small error of approximation
and in fact for those who are aware of
approximation theory two or functions uh
or point functions in the classical
literature
uh it turns out that these problems they
generalize and in fact they achieve the
approximations that are given in the or
given for the or functions and which are
obtained a long time back like khan
lenin and schwensky
so what's very interesting is that this
approximation is exactly what's needed
to prove an area law for this class of
systems
uh frustration free and locally gapped
systems in two dimensions
and
it's quite surprising why
why exactly do these problems
serve the right tool and the central
question that we leave behind is that is
this approximation achievable for all
gap systems if it can be done then there
would be basically that would resolve
the area of injection in 2d
so with that let me quickly tell you
about more applications so even
more recently quantum circuit load
bounds have been developed using
chebyshev approximation and so on and
even the ground state repression
algorithms by these days it works with
that thanks and sorry for overspilling
stuffing a bit
great
so
questions while continuously
do these fancier polynomials from the
last couple of slides also come out of
optimization in some way like chebyshev
polynomials come out of acceleration and
things like this
this this come out these are sort of
derived from chebyshev in certain way
but i don't think they
they have a optimization interpretation
yet it's not clear
[Music]